The heart of a shader is the actual shader program it runs. This program is
passed to the GPU as a string of characters. I'll repeat that, since it's a bit
unusual. Instead of sending compiled code or binary data, or some other
processed information to the driver, you actually send it a string of
characters. WebGL shaders are written in GLSLES, the OpenGL Shading Language
for Embedded Systems. No one calls it GLSLES. Everyone simply says GLSL. If you
use DirectX, you'd use HLSL -- thy are High Level Shading Language. In either
case, the character string is what gets sent to the graphics driver. The
graphics driver compiles these into assembly instructions that are sent to the
GPU. Here's how to create a shader string in Javascript. The first line is how
Javascript says it's going to define an array. What we're doing here is
defining a string for each line of our program. That's one way to get shader
programs into 3GS, but it's usually not the most convenient. There are all
these quote marks and commas, which are visually confusing and a pain to add
and maintain. That said, one advantage of this approach is that you can glue
together strings on the fly to make shaders. This is in fact exactly what 3GS
does. When you ask for three lights on a shiny material, it creates a custom
shader for exactly those elements. If you have a specific fixed shader in mind,
an easier way is to make your program a separate text resource. I won't work
through the mechanics here. This isn't really a web programming class. But see
the code in this course's get hub repository for how we do it. Basically, you
create a separate text file or script element that has your program's text in
it.